the solution to this question is list
preference when the setting is tapped it
presents a list of choices as a dialog
when the user selects an option it's
saved into shared preferences here are
the steps to do this within the pref
general XML file we add a list
preference we give it a title and this
maps to the string temperature units we
also need to give it a key for the
shared preferences and so we specify
that to be units if there is no value in
shared preferences then it falls back to
a default value of metric the preference
also wants to know the list of all
possible values here the two possible
values are metric or imperial so we
passed those in as an array into entry
values now these are just constants for
use within the logic of our app these
are not the user visible strings so we
need to create entries which is an array
of user visible strings that maps to
each one of these possible values to
have the temperature unit preference
show up in the settings activity we
modify the oncreate method we add this
line of code for the temperature unit
setting when the user makes a selection
in the dialog we set the preference
summary to be the new value of either
metric or imperial here when we receive
a high and low temperature we read from
shared preferences to know whether the
temperature should be converted into
imperial units or left as metric then we
return the formatted string for display
in the UI that completes the code for
saving the temperature unit setting